this is the center run by medicine
sovereignty air which says at least
three of its workers there have been
killed but 30 more are still missing and
so it was hit by several strikes
actually you can still see what looks
like flames inside that building a surly
you can see with a black on the outside
of the windows had ferocious the fire in
that building was following that attack
never Lazarus is live in Delhi for as
monitoring this situation and there's no
doubt level just how serious this is the
the US and missing that it may have been
responsible for this attack that's right
we've got statements from the
spokesperson of the international forces
there Brian tribe us telling us that the
u.s. conducted these airstrikes at two
fifteen in the morning local time
against individuals threatening their
forces which has which then resulted in
collateral damage to the medical
facility the the incident is being
investigated by the US forces and NATO
but nevertheless there has been this has
caused immense grief and shock across
the region especially in Afghanistan
where this was the only hospital
catering to the northeastern part of the
country there were a hundred and five
patients and their caretakers plus about
a hundred about 80 MSF staff in the
hospital when this took place there are
reports which we can't confirm that this
bombing went on for about an hour and a
half where we cannot confirm that but
nevertheless this has this has created a
huge shock in the country especially
when when two days ago that's on
Wednesday the Afghan for the Afghan
government the told reporters that they
are almost in control of the entire city
but that doesn't seem like it